Esiste un [musica] singolo tocco della
durata di non più di 5 secondi che la
maggior parte degli uomini non usa mai,
ma [musica] che può cambiare
radicalmente la percezione che una donna
matura ha di te, più di quanto
potrebbero [musica] fare mesi di
conversazioni perfette. Oggi imparerai
tutte e sette e quando questo video sarà
finito comprenderai qualcosa sulla
connessione emotiva che la maggior parte
delle persone [musica] non scopre mai in
un'intera vita, perché queste non sono
tecniche, sono forme di comunicazione e
il sistema nervoso di una donna matura
le recepisce con una precisione che
nessuna frase [musica] è mai stata in
grado di replicare. Se questo video ti
ha insegnato qualcosa sulla connessione
che avresti voluto sapere anni fa,
clicca subito sul pulsante [musica] Mi
piace, ci vuole solo un secondo e ci fa
capire che desideri altri contenuti così
approfonditi. Prima di proseguire vorrei
farvi una domanda sincera. [musica] Qual
è il tipo di contatto fisico che vi ha
fatto sentire più compresi emotivamente
nella vostra vita? Non impressionati o
desiderati, [musica] ma veramente visti?
Scrivete la vostra risposta nei commenti
qui sotto. [musica] Sono davvero curioso
di leggere i vostri commenti. Pensate a
qualcuno nella vostra vita. Un fratello,
un [musica] caro amico, un uomo che
stimate, che ha un'autentica
affettuosità con le donne, ma a cui
nessuno ha mai insegnato cosa significhi
davvero la presenza emotiva attraverso
il contatto [musica] fisico. Ci sta
provando, gli manca solo qualcosa che
nessuno gli ha [musica] mai dato. Questo
video è per lui. Per favore,
condividetelo con lui oggi stesso. Se è
la prima volta che visiti Feminine
[musica] Psychology, sappi che ogni
video che creiamo va oltre la superficie
[musica] delle relazioni, addentrandosi
nella psicologia, nelle neuroscienze
[musica] e nelle verità emotive di ciò
che le donne provano e a cui reagiscono.
Iscriviti ora per non perderti nessun
video come questo. [musica] Se ciò che
hai imparato in questo video ti aiuta a
costruire una connessione che porti
davvero a qualcosa di concreto,
considera di lasciare un grazie mille
qui [musica] sotto. Ogni contributo
supporta direttamente la ricerca e la
produzione che rendono possibili
contenuti come questo.
Ecco una verità sulle donne mature di
cui quasi nessuno parla onestamente.
Quando una donna raggiunge i 35, i 40,
[musica] i 50 anni, ha già sentito di
tutto. Ogni frase lusinghiera, ogni
dichiarazione attentamente [musica]
studiata, ogni messaggio di testo
studiato per sembrare spontaneo. Ha
sentito uomini citar le poesie. ha
sentito uomini investire soldi veri
cercando [musica] di comportarsi in
tutti i modi che la cultura impone.
Eppure, se le chiedeste di descrivere i
momenti in cui si è sentita più
autenticamente legata [musica] a
qualcuno, sapete cosa descriverebbe?
Non le cene, non le parole, non i grandi
gesti di cui ha raccontato la storia
[musica] 100 volte. Lei descriveva un
tocco, un [musica] contatto fisico
specifico, silenzioso, senza fretta, che
arrivava senza preavviso e comunicava
qualcosa che nessuna frase accuratamente
scelta era mai riuscita a dire, perché
ecco cosa rivela alla scienza del tatto,
qualcosa che la maggior parte delle
persone [musica] non impara mai. Il
corpo umano possiede un sistema neurale
specifico per ricevere ed elaborare il
contatto sociale. Una classe di fibre
nervose [musica]
chiamate afferenze tattilici risponde in
modo specifico al contatto lento,
delicato e intenzionale e non invia
segnali alla corteccia sensoriale dove
elaboriamo le informazioni. [musica]
Inviano i loro segnali direttamente alla
corteccia insulare dove elaboriamo le
emozioni, [musica] la sicurezza e il
senso di appartenenza.
In termini pratici ciò significa che un
particolare tipo di tocco bypassa la
parte del cervello che analizza e valuta
[musica] e arriva quasi immediatamente
alla parte che semplicemente sente. I
ricercatori dell'UC Berkley hanno
condotto uno studio in cui a coppie di
sconosciuti [musica] è stato chiesto di
comunicare 12 emozioni distinte
utilizzando solo un breve contatto
fisico. Niente parole, nessuna
espressione facciale visibile, [musica]
solo il tocco. I risultati hanno stupito
il team di ricerca. [musica] I
partecipanti sono stati in grado di
identificare emozioni come compassione,
gratitudine e amore attraverso il solo
tatto con una notevole precisione.
Non perché il [musica] tatto sia magico,
ma perché quando viene trasmesso con
sincera intenzione veicola informazioni
che il linguaggio non è in grado di
esprimere.
Una donna matura, grazie ad anni di
esperienza [musica] vissuta, ha
sviluppato una capacità raffinata di
distinguere tra un tocco intenzionale e
un tocco eseguito. Il suo sistema
nervoso percepisce la differenza prima
ancora che la sua mente abbia finito di
analizzarla. [musica]
E ciò che sto per condividere con voi
sono sette modi specifici per comunicare
[musica] attraverso il tatto esattamente
ciò che lei desidera sentire da molto
tempo. Due di questi dettagli vi
sembreranno così insignificanti [musica]
che sarete tentate di ignorarli. Non
fatelo. Sono proprio questi i tocchi
[musica] che le donne mature, con le
loro stesse parole e in numerosi studi
descrivono [musica]
come quelli che hanno cambiato qualcosa
dentro di loro. Il primo tocco è quello
che chiamo l'elevazione del polso. Si
tratta del gesto di prenderle
delicatamente [musica] e con fermezza il
polso, non la mano, ma il polso, mentre
[musica] la guida attraverso un
ostacolo, un gradino, una soglia, una
superficie irregolare, una folla.
Due [musica] dita e il pollice si
stringono appena sotto il palmo attorno
al punto più stretto [musica] del polso.
Perché il polso e non la mano? Perché il
polso è un punto intimo in un modo che
la mano non lo è. Il punto in cui si
sente il battito si trova a pochi
millimetri sotto la superficie. [musica]
Quando le dita lo circondano, si entra
in contatto con il battito cardiaco,
[musica]
un'informazione involontaria, biologica
e completamente inalterabile. [musica]
Il suo sistema nervoso categorizza
istantaneamente ciò che riceve dalla tua
mano. Questa persona è calma, stabile
[musica] e pienamente consapevole di me.
Non sta eseguendo una mossa, sta
effettivamente prestando attenzione. Per
una donna matura che ha trascorso anni
[musica] a essere afferrata, spinta con
fretta o guidata con non curanza, la
sensazione di qualcuno che le prende il
polso [musica] con deliberata
delicatezza è sorprendentemente
piacevole. Comunica precisione, [musica]
presenza, quel tipo di cura che non si
ostenta. La gentilezza non è debolezza,
[musica] è forza resa precisa. Ma il
secondo tocco è quello che blocca
completamente [musica]
la maggior parte delle donne a metà del
pensiero perché richiede qualcosa che la
maggior parte degli uomini è
semplicemente troppo impaziente [musica]
per dare. Secondo tocco, il bacio sulla
fronte di 3 [musica] secondi. Un bacio
sulla fronte non è una novità. Ciò che
rende diversa questa versione [musica] è
la durata. 3 secondi interi in totale
immobilità. Labbra premute delicatamente
sulla sua fronte. Occhi chiusi, nessun
movimento, nessuna parola,
[schiarire la voce][musica]
solo presenza. Questa distinzione ha un
peso maggiore di quanto la maggior parte
delle persone [musica] si renda conto.
Un bacio che dura meno di un secondo è
un saluto, un bacio che dura 3 secondi è
una dichiarazione. E la dichiarazione
che esprime è questa: "Non ho fretta di
vivere questo momento, non sono già
altrove, [musica] sono completamente
qui."
La dottoressa Sw Johnson, le cui decenni
di ricerca sull'attaccamento in età
adulta hanno radicalmente ridefinito il
modo in cui i terapeuti comprendono
l'amore e la connessione, [musica] ha
scritto ampiamente su quelli che lei
definisce momenti decisivi nel legame
affettivo. Si tratta di brevi
interazioni fisiche che attivano o
disattivano il sistema [musica] di
attaccamento negli adulti. La stessa
architettura neurologica che si sviluppa
inizialmente tra un neonato [musica] e
chi si prende cura di lui. Questo
sistema non scompare in età adulta,
semplicemente [musica] si disattiva
quando non viene soddisfatto. Un bacio
prolungato sulla fronte lo attiva. Per
una donna matura che ha trascorso anni a
proteggere un sistema di [musica]
attaccamento ripetutamente ignorato o
respinto, questo tocco non è solo
piacevole, [musica]
è come un riconoscimento, come se
finalmente qualcuno parlasse
fluentemente una lingua che aveva smesso
di aspettarsi di sentire. [musica]
La pazienza nei piccoli momenti dice più
di 1000 promesse.
Terzo tocco, la piega dei capelli.
Questo è il gesto di allungare
delicatamente la mano e spostare una
ciocca di capelli dal suo viso. Magari
le è caduta sulla [musica] guancia
durante una conversazione, magari una
brezza l'ha spostata mentre siete
entrambi all'aperto. [musica]
Senza esitare lentamente, allunghi la
mano e gliela sistemi dietro l'orecchio.
Questo tocco agisce a un livello che le
sue [musica] dimensioni non lasciano
trasparire. Per farlo correttamente devi
prima essere abbastanza vicino da notare
i dettagli [musica] specifici del suo
viso. Devi aver prestato sufficiente
attenzione per vederli e devi sentirti
sufficientemente a tuo agio con lei e
abbastanza sicuro del calore che vi lega
da entrare nel suo spazio personale
[musica] senza essere invitato. Quando
tutte e tre queste condizioni sono
presenti, cosa comunica il gesto?
[musica]
dice, "Stavo osservando il tuo viso,
volevo vederlo chiaramente [musica] e
non ho avuto paura di fare qualcosa a
riguardo per una donna che ha trascorso
lunghi periodi [musica] della sua vita
con persone che a malapena alzavano lo
sguardo, fisicamente presente nella
stanza, ma emotivamente invisibile,
essere vista con quel livello di
dettaglio [musica]
produce una reazione che potrebbe
davvero faticare ad esprimere a parole.
Non è un gesto eclatante ed è proprio
per questo che funziona.
Il quarto tipo di contatto è quello
effettivamente utilizzato nella terapia
di coppia, [musica] non come esercizio
simbolico, ma come intervento
clinicamente prescritto e non è quello
che la maggior parte delle [musica]
persone si aspetterebbe.
Numero 4, la mano sul cuore. Durante una
conversazione significativa o anche in
un momento di silenzio assoluto,
[musica]
le prendi delicatamente la mano e la
appoggi piatta sul tuo petto, sul cuore.
Non spieghi il perché, non racconti cosa
sta succedendo, [musica] semplicemente
le prendi la mano e la metti lì. Questo
contatto funziona attraverso un
meccanismo che i ricercatori chiamano
condivisione interocc, [musica] l'atto
di dare a un'altra persona accesso
diretto al tuo stato fisiologico
interno. Il tuo battito cardiaco non può
essere provato, [musica] non può essere
regolato per un pubblico. Quando il suo
palmo è piatto contro il tuo petto, sta
ricevendo qualcosa di completamente
[musica]
non filtrato su chi sei in quel momento.
E ciò che comunica non è solo calore,
comunica fiducia. Hai affidato nelle sue
mani qualcosa che non puoi controllare
[musica] direttamente. La fiducia non si
esprime a parole, si percepisce. Per una
donna matura che ha sentito dire "Mi
fido di te" da persone [musica] che non
l'hanno mai dimostrato, sentire il ritmo
involontario del tuo cuore sotto il
palmo della sua mano è qualcosa di
categoricamente diverso da ogni parola
rassicurante [musica] che abbia mai
ricevuto.
È una prova. E una prova per una donna
che ha imparato a essere scettica nei
confronti delle dichiarazioni significa
tutto. Ed eccoci giunti al quinto punto.
Questo è quello che stavo quasi per
[musica] escludere dalla lista, perché
nel momento in cui si comprende
esattamente come funziona, inizia a
sembrare quasi ingiusto.
Numero [musica] 5, il movimento lento
del braccio.
Con la punta delle dita, non con tutto
il palmo, solo con la punta, tracciate
lentamente un percorso lungo
l'avambraccio dall'interno del gomito
verso il polso [musica]
oppure dalla spalla verso il gomito.
Lentamente, con delicatezza, con
precisione.
Come accennato in precedenza, le fibre
nervose afferenti tattili C rispondono a
un solo tipo di stimolo, un contatto
lento, delicato e carezzevole a circa 5
[musica] cm/ second. non rispondono alla
pressione, non rispondono alla
temperatura, [musica] solo a movimenti
lenti, intenzionali e leggeri sulla
pelle e il loro segnale non raggiunge la
corteccia sensoriale, dove il tatto
ordinario viene elaborato come
informazione. Viaggia invece verso la
corteccia insulare, [musica]
dove si generano effettivamente la
vicinanza emotiva, il senso di [musica]
appartenenza sociale e le sensazioni di
intimità. In altre parole, quando
[musica] le tue dita si muovono
lentamente lungo il suo braccio, non le
stai dando una sensazione, le stai dando
[musica] un'emozione e le emozioni
generate nella corteccia insulare non
sono facili da analizzare, spiegare o
razionalizzare, [musica]
vengono semplicemente vissute.
Una donna matura percepirà un
cambiamento nell'energia tra voi quando
farete questo e potrebbe non essere in
grado di definire cosa sia cambiato.
[musica]
Il suo sistema nervoso ha registrato
qualcosa prima che la sua mente
cosciente [musica] avesse la possibilità
di valutarlo. È proprio in quello spazio
tra sensazione [musica] e spiegazione
che risiede la vera attrazione.
E il sesto tocco è quello [musica] che
riscrive di condizionamento emotivo in
un singolo istante, senza parole.
[musica]
Sesto tocco, il disegno senza parole.
È questo il momento in cui, senza
preamboli né richieste di permesso,
allunghi la mano e annulli la distanza
fisica che vi separa. [musica]
Il tuo braccio si posa sulla sua spalla
o la tua mano trova la curva [musica]
della sua vita e senza una parola la
attiri dolcemente a te. Nessun [musica]
annuncio, nessun venite qui, solo il
movimento in sé. I ricercatori che
studiano l'attaccamento [musica]
descrivono uno schema comportamentale
chiamato ricerca di prossimità. [musica]
La spinta istintiva delle persone con un
attaccamento sicuro a ridurre la
distanza fisica dalla persona a cui
tengono. È uno dei marcatori
comportamentali più costanti che
distinguono un legame autentico [musica]
da un affetto simulato. Quando la
stringi a te senza un motivo preciso,
non come preludio a qualcos'altro, non
per attirare l'attenzione, [musica]
non perché desideri altro che la sua
vicinanza, stai esprimendo direttamente
quell'istinto. [musica]
Il tuo corpo sta dicendo senza parole la
distanza non mi convinceva. Ti volevo
qui per una donna matura che ha
trascorso anni [musica] in relazioni in
cui la vicinanza fisica doveva essere
guadagnata, in cui doveva essere
abbastanza gradevole, abbastanza
attraente, [musica]
sufficiente per giustificare l'affetto
ricevuto, questo gesto [musica]
silenzioso può avere un impatto che
sorprende persino lei, perché non le
chiede nulla, [musica] semplicemente la
sceglie così com'è.
proprio ora. E quando una donna che ha
passato anni a prepararsi ad affrontare
determinate situazioni scopre un uomo
che la cerca [musica] senza alcuna
riserva, cosa immagini che accada dentro
di lei?
Il settimo tocco è quello che ho
ottenuto per [musica] ultimo, perché
tutto ciò che è venuto prima ha portato
a questo.
Tocco numero [musica] 7, l'abbraccio
della sincronizzazione completa.
Non un [musica] abbraccio di saluto, non
un abbraccio di addio, non una breve
stretta di cortesia che finisce nel
momento in cui uno dei due decide che
debba finire. Un abbraccio completo,
petto [musica] a petto, con entrambe le
braccia intrecciate, che duri almeno 20
secondi [musica] e in cui non sai tu a
staccarti per primo. La tieni tra le
braccia e respiri. Ecco cosa accade
realmente nel corpo umano quando un
abbraccio si protrae per più di 20
secondi. L'ossito il neurotrasmettitore
responsabile del legame affettivo, della
sicurezza emotiva e della fiducia
profonda viene rilasciata nel flusso
[musica] sanguigno. Il cortisolo, il
principale ormone dello stress,
diminuisce sensibilmente.
La frequenza cardiaca si abbassa, la
pressione sanguigna diminuisce. Il
sistema nervoso inizia la transizione
dall'attivazione simpatica, [musica]
la reazione di attacco o fuga alla
regolazione parasimpatica [musica] che è
lo stato biologico in cui diventa
possibile una vera apertura emotiva.
Non si può fingere, non si può replicare
nemmeno con le parole più perfette
[musica] del mondo e non si può avere
fretta. Nel momento in cui si affretta
si rovina tutto. La cosa più potente che
puoi offrire [musica]
è semplicemente non andartene. Ma ecco
l'intuizione che cambia tutto. Quando un
abbraccio [musica] dura abbastanza a
lungo, tra due persone inizia a
verificarsi un fenomeno che i
ricercatori chiamano sincronizzazione
respiratoria.
I ritmi respiratori iniziano a
sincronizzarsi. [musica]
Gradualmente, inconsciamente
inspirazione ed espirazione assumono lo
stesso ritmo [musica] lento.
La ricerca sulla sincronia
interpersonale ha dimostrato che la
respirazione sincronizzata produce un
aumento misurabile della sensazione di
vicinanza, della fiducia e di quello che
i ricercatori descrivono come un
autentico senso di unione. Un'esperienza
neurologica di presenza condivisa
[musica] che nessun'altra forma di
comunicazione può produrre con la stessa
efficacia.
Non la stai semplicemente tenendo in
braccio, [musica] ti stai sincronizzando
biologicamente con lei per una donna
matura, una donna che ha trascorso anni
a tenere uniti tutti gli altri, [musica]
che ha costruito la propria forza
emotiva non per scelta, ma per
necessità, che è diventata il proprio
punto di riferimento [musica] perché
doveva farlo. Cosa significa quando
qualcuno la stringe a sé abbastanza a
lungo da farle perdere la resistenza?
Significa tutto ciò che nessuna parola
che le sia mai stata detta è riuscita a
esprimere appieno.
Non perché sia romantico, non perché sia
impressionante, [musica]
ma perché è un sollievo. Per la prima
volta dopo tanto [musica] tempo, non è
lei a tenere tutto insieme, è lei a
essere tenuta. E l'uomo che può darle
questo, che capisce che a volte il gesto
più potente che può fare è semplicemente
rifiutarsi di lasciarla andare. è l'uomo
che ricorderà in modo diverso da tutti
quelli che ha conosciuto prima. Non si
sentirà semplicemente attratta da lui,
lo sceglierà consapevolmente,
ripetutamente,
con ogni parte di sé che ha gelosamente
protetto, tenendola al riparo da persone
che non meritavano la [musica] sua
apertura.
Se questo video vi ha offerto una nuova
e autentica comprensione di cosa
significhi e come si percepisca [musica]
la sicurezza emotiva attraverso il
contatto fisico, cliccate subito sul
pulsante [musica] Mi piace. È un piccolo
gesto che per noi significa moltissimo.
Ecco cosa vorrei che riflettessi
onestamente. Quale di questi [musica]
sette gesti pensi di aver trascurato sia
nel dare che nel ricevere? La risposta
[musica]
potrebbe sorprenderti. Scrivila nei
commenti qui sotto. Pensate a una donna
che amate, [musica] una sorella,
un'amica intima, qualcuno che ha portato
silenziosamente un peso troppo grande
per [musica] troppo tempo senza mai
chiedere aiuto. Questo video mostra cosa
si prova davvero ad essere abbracciati,
non fisicamente, ma veramente accolti.
[musica]
Lei ha bisogno di vederlo. Per favore
condividetelo con lei oggi [musica]
stesso. La psicologia femminile nasce
per andare oltre i consigli
superficiali, addentrandosi nelle vere
neuroscienze, [musica] nella ricerca
sull'attaccamento e nell'autentica
esperienza emotiva di ciò che le donne
provano e di cui hanno bisogno nelle
relazioni. Se questo è il tipo di
contenuto che desideri, iscriviti
[musica] subito. Nuovi video vengono
pubblicati ogni settimana. Se ciò che
hai imparato oggi ti aiuta a costruire
un legame duraturo nella tua vita,
[musica] considera di lasciare un grazie
mille qui sotto. Non stai solo
supportando un canale, ma stai
investendo in contenuti che aiutano le
persone a comprendersi [musica] a un
livello più profondo e questo è più
importante di quanto la maggior parte
delle persone si [musica] renda conto.
Sette tochi, ognuno basato sulle
neuroscienze, sulla ricerca
sull'attaccamento e sulla vita emotiva
reale di donne [musica] che hanno
vissuto abbastanza esperienze da sapere
cosa significhi una connessione [musica]
autentica. Nessuna di queste situazioni
richiede circostanze straordinarie
[musica] o una tempistica perfetta.
Nessuna richiede un vocabolario più
ricco [musica] o un curriculum più
impressionante. Richiedono l'unica cosa
che è sempre a tua disposizione.
[musica]
La tua attenzione è autentica, senza
fretta e pienamente presente. [musica]
Ma ora che hai capito cosa crea un
legame emotivo attraverso il contatto
fisico, c'è qualcosa di altrettanto
importante che ti aspetta, [musica]
perché lei reagirà, inizierà a mostrarti
i modi specifici, costanti e spesso
[musica] molto silenziosi che si sta
aprendo, che si fida di te, che sta
iniziando a sceglierti. E la maggior
parte degli uomini non coglie affatto
[musica] questi segnali, non perché non
ci facciano caso, ma perché nessuno ha
mai insegnato loro cosa cercare. Ecco di
cosa parla il nostro prossimo video. I
precisi segnali comportamentali che una
donna matura invia quando decide che
qualcuno merita la sua fiducia e il
motivo per cui la maggior parte degli
uomini li ignora completamente. [musica]
Lo trovate proprio ora sullo schermo.
Guardatelo subito.